international waffle day is next tuesday
but we're getting a jump on the
celebration today joining us from
zephyr's cafe at the sahara we have chef
jose is here and also derek he's the
director of restaurants welcome you two
thank you very much thank you for having
us well thanks for being here what
special do you have on national waffle
day so on tuesday august 24th at sahara
las vegas at zephyrs we're doing a peach
cobbler waffle so chef created this he
kind of created a dessert we wanted
something that people could enjoy for
breakfast but also a savory side for
dessert as well so and this is a great
tie-in because that's what we're going
to assemble today how do we how do we
build this correct i'll let chef take
that all right chef what's the first
step okay first we have our waffle over
here i have mine over here okay just
follow my lead
the waffle is pre-made you have your
waffle iron right there it's hot and
ready to go
come on scoop it out of there how hot
should that waffle maker be for making
them at home that thing should be
scolding hot
well i would say set it to about four
four or four settings for your waffle
making
that's how it works yeah for your waffle
maker yeah so first
these are our macerated peaches
they're cooked in bourbon sugar and
butter oh okay and we're cooking this
the night before the morning of this is
already done before you put on top of
your waffles
i like this because someone watching
right now they can do this they can buy
this at albertsons and assemble this
themselves oh it's very easy but i would
prefer fresh peaches
of course
who wants we want choose fresh peaches
all the time
so what are some of the waffles other
waffle creations you guys have at the
restaurant so uh chef did chiro waffles
as well and then one of our favorites
that we have today is frosted flakes
french toast so we wanted people to
enjoy breakfast items but also have a
regular items with a twist of ours and
then kind of remember your childhood
right so all those fun flavors that you
had cheeros frosted flakes things like
that yeah we see it right here on the
table the creations that you guys have
it's really over the top it's filling
it's delicious and it's a great way to
celebrate national waffle day over at
zephyrs and what's the item you're
putting here
this is our uh homemade whipped cream
infused with peaches and vanilla i love
all the homemade ingredients that you
guys have chef wanted to make a fun dish
but then also like you said dishes that
people would enjoy at home and like you
know we were thinking people love peach
cobbler and so we just kind of combined
the two all right got about 30 seconds
here what else we put on top of this all
right here you go this creation i'll put
you to work here you go add the brown
sugar brown sugar ready to go add it on
top put it on top here yes sir big
chunks of brown sugar
it's actually a shortbread recipe so you
just add the mint and there you are now
i feel like this is so sweet it looks so
delicious i don't have to put syrup on
top of it do i no you serve it with
syrup but you don't have to a lot of our
dishes chef wants it served and eaten as
it's served all right i'm just gonna
take a bite of this thing before we toss
it to break zephyr's over at the sahara
you guys are open seven days a week
right seven days a week we're from seven
to ten open at 11 on friday and saturday
wow
wow rocky you can have the rest of this
this is good thank you guys for joining
us we appreciate it absolutely national
waffle date happens on tuesday las vegas
now we'll be right